how do we go on evolution yes exactly
you shouldn't be talking about this at
all Oh Jay trial to that hero cop Mark
Fuhrman fundo not touching that one
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer today we are covering another
episode of It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia
this time it is Reynolds vs. Reynolds
the serial defense as always be sure to
comment in the form of an objection if
you disagree with me and while you're
there let me know what show or movie I
should do next and of course stick
around until the end of the video where
I give this episode of It's Always Sunny
in Philadelphia a grade for legal
realism so without further ado let's dig
into Reynolds versus Reynolds more
distracted driving with the bowl of
cereal distracted driving is a big
problem never drive while distracted
always a bad idea I'm Sandra dumb guy so
I'm sitting at a red light at a dead
stop and Frank rams into me out of
nowhere and now he's saying he's not
gonna pay for the damages I mean did you
know that the man cannot see I could see
I got glasses
I just need new lenses the lenses are
what make the glasses work Frank if you
were driving around without the use of
sight then that is completely
irresponsible and you need to pay for
the damages oh man
this is actually incredible because this
debate harkens back to one of the
seminal cases in law school specifically
the case of Hadley vs. Baxendale where
someone was supposed to deliver a
crankshaft to a mill and the mill owner
sued the delivery person not just for
the exact damages that occurred but for
the loss of income that occurred for the
days afterwards for failing to receive
the crankshaft which was necessary for
the mill the court of Exchequer in
England which is equivalent to the
Supreme Court in the United States held
that the delivery person couldn't be
held responsible for the consequential
damages that occurred as a result of
failing to meet their delivery deadline
and what they held is that you're only
responsible for the damages that are
reasonably foreseeable as a result of
your negligence so I think what's going
to happen throughout this entire episode
is this going to be a question about
whether it was reasonably foreseeable
for Frank to have caused these damages
to the interior of Dennis's car and it's
not an easy question it's hilarious to
me that they set this up basically as a
hypothetical that you would have to deal
with as a first-year law student and
it's also funny considering how bad the
last legal episode of It's Always Sunny
in Philadelphia was objection she's not
a cat your honor this is I think gonna
get a much higher grade he was eating a
bowl of cereal when I hit him all over
the interior and those are the only
damages to the car you're eating a bowl
of cereal yes while you were driving yes
it's not that crazy that's not what this
is about so the only damages were
interior justify myself to you you know
what I'm gonna do I take it aboard
second nobody needs to go to court here
there's no reason we can't settle this
ourselves like civilized adults no no we
can't do so I'm gonna take him to court
I'm gonna sue him and I'm gonna win
Dennis you don't want to go anywhere
near a court
how many bench warrants for sexual
misconduct do you have would there be
bench warrants for sexual misconduct I
don't think that's a thing first off who
is the defendant in this matter
that's not a statement all right well
irregardless I would like to know as
Frank's lawyer who I am persecuting or
who I'm defending yeah prosecuting okay
let me just nip this whole thing in the
bud right now stop treating this like
it's a trial and like this is a
courtroom yeah but the table's
yeah but I was against that too okay
let's just present the facts to each
other and then let's decide as a
majority who's in the right that being
said Frank would be the defendant I'm
not the defendant now that implies that
I am guilty he's right if anyone's ever
accused of anything I automatically
assume they're guilty right yeah it's
unfortunate that a lot of people feel
that way if someone is accused of
something that they have a presumption
of guilt that should not be the case
it's the prosecutor or the plaintiff
that bears the burden that being said
here clearly Frank would be the
defendant he's the one that was driving
he's the one that caused the things that
are potentially damages here there's no
debate here Frank would be the defendant
I'm finished where have you been for the
last three hours I have been making this
what the hell is that it's the trial
meter it shows how we each feel
throughout the trial yeah I made little
gavels with our names on it and we can
move them accordingly and at the end
whoever has the most gavels on their
side wins it took you three hours to
make that yeah Mac let me tell you
something nobody is gonna want to use
that because it's so stupid we are
dealing with a serious issue here as
ridiculous is this sort of cartoon
interpretation of which way all the
different people are leaning is it's
actually not a bad way of deciding who
in this sort of quasi arbitration is
going to win here obviously the parties
are going to vote for themselves but
ironically in an arbitration which this
sort of is you would often have a
three-judge panel sometimes you would
have only one judge or arbitrator but
often you would have a three arbitrator
panel that's made up of former judges
and guess what the majority wins so if
you're able to convince two out of the
three arbitrators then you would win
your case in arbitration so it's kind of
a funny version of what happens in real
life this is a courtroom please on the
judge no you're not can I be the bailiff
you are not anything oh and that is one
of the reasons why you never want to
represent yourself you have too much
skin in the game it's too hard to be
objective and it is too easy to have an
outburst like that
Dennis should not be representing
himself in this matter he should really
be relying on his putative counselor Dee
will you please read this document
mm-hmm by the power of the Commonwealth
of Pennsylvania read mental institution
hereby decrees Frank Reynolds to not
have donkey brains
official all right so there's a lot of
stuff going on here interestingly
charlie is not doing a terrible terrible
job of laying the proper foundation that
he needs to enter this thing into
evidence and in fact like few legal
shows he actually says that he wants to
enter this particular document into
evidence you actually don't see that all
that often he missed a few steps number
one this document is hearsay regardless
of where it came from because he's
trying to use her for the truth the
matter asserted that Frank in fact does
not have donkey brains so he has hearsay
problems to deal with he has to
establish that there is some hearsay
exception but he has gone part of the
way towards there he has established
that Frank received this document at
some point and he has some basis to say
what this document is he still needs to
show that it was a business record of
the mental institution and the only way
to do that is to get a custodian of the
mental institution so he certainly
hasn't laid all of the foundation but he
is part of the way there which is more
than I can say for a lot of legal TV
shows that's pretty funny all the kids
in the neighborhood knew I got sent
upstate so they started calling me
Frankie donkey brains and it was very
traumatic oh so I got my mommy to drive
me back up to the loony bin where they
signed this official certificate
exonerating me of all donkey brains yeah
great what does this have to do with
anything yeah that is a good objection
what Charlie is trying to do here is to
enter character evidence on behalf of
Frank he's trying to say that Frank has
a character for lack of donkey brains
which is a ridiculous sentence for me to
have to say right now but anyway that's
what he's trying to do and what he's
trying to show is that on the day in
question of the accident he's saying
that Frank was not acting with donkey
brains and therefore could not have been
negligent in driving his car so at base
this is a really good example of why
character evidence should not be allowed
just because Frank might have had a
character for lack of donkey brains when
he was a child doesn't mean he didn't
act negligently
when he ran into Dennis in this
particular instance what well we don't
want a doggy on the road eating cereal
we know Frank's not a donkey how we know
you're not a donkey brain man yep a good
example of why character evidence is bad
idea you're trying to prove a negative
here to show that you weren't a donkey
brain when you were the victim of this
accident the fact that Frank has this
certificate means nothing and this is a
specious argument that Charlie is using
here it shouldn't hold any water why
would I have a certificate you don't
know the burden of proof is not on me
the defendant will answer the question
the defendant just answer the question
those are two contradictory statements
he's not the defendant that's accurate
but he does have the burden of proof
here he has to prove that it is more
likely than not that Frank was negligent
and that the damages that he's suffered
are attributable to that negligence
right would you like a glass of wine
yeah alright oh why not have a glass of
wine I mean after all I'm so sorry
a whoopsie whoopsie see I bashed into
Frank while he was at a dead stop that's
completely my fault Frank I will pay for
all the damages to your shirt case
closed
oh well when you put it like that you
got me you know I'm on Dennis's side no
he just convinced me all right I think
Charlie's being facetious here but
Dennis's argument here really goes to
the heart of the matter he is trying to
establish that the damages that he
suffered the liquid coming out of his
cereal bowl and ruining the interior of
his car are analogous to running into
Frank and spilling the red wine onto his
shirt this is what lawyers do all the
time we take case law we make analogies
to prior cases that involve a similar
set of facts and we say that the facts
at issue are similar to the facts that
have gone before and here he is trying
to make an analogy between the liquid
the milk in a cereal bowl to the liquid
the wine that was in the wine glass so
really good job by Dennis making an
argument that goes to the heart of the
matter here whether it was reasonably
foreseeable for Frank to have caused the
damages to the inside of Dennis's car it
occurs to me that Frank assumed
responsibility for a potential spill the
second he took the wine he's right I
knew the risk so in this circumstance it
would appear that Frank is at fault and
therefore in the car
dennis is at fault I am on Frank's side
case closed that's another good argument
there is a doctrine called assumption of
risk in negligence law sometimes if you
do an inherently dangerous act as the
victim and you are damaged as a result
of both someone's negligence and your
own actions the law imputes an
assumption of risk and it is an
affirmative defense to a claim of
negligence it's a doctrine that comes
into play when a victim knowingly and
voluntarily takes on the risks
associated with a certain activity so
for example if you were trespassing and
you saw a sign that said enter at your
own risk dangerous condition
or caution guard dog you might be
subject to the affirmative defense of
assumption of risk because you knowingly
took on the risks associated with that
particular behavior so this is a great
argument for Mac to make this is a
defense that gets used in courts all the
time
I don't think it applies in this
particular situation but let's see what
the other arguments are and see how it
comes out I'm gonna ask you one more
time do you or do you not believe that
you can create a superhuman race of
strongmen through genetic mutation and
evolution
uh no that's ridiculous d what are you
talking about what are you talking about
you were just you were just telling
Charlie this morning all about the oh I
have you seen X man and in my seed and I
was joking with Charlie they could never
happen in the real world d that's a
comic-book thing he's credible wait wait
wait wait wait wait a minute Mac why
don't you believe that huh well I'm just
wondering why don't you believe that you
could pass down a gene that would
eventually evolve into a race of
supermen why I like where dennis is
going here this is one of the reasons
why you should never lie in court it's
because a good lawyer will be able to
suss out your lies and show that you are
not a credible person when you're on the
stand often credibility is important not
in the sense that they're showing here
but in the sense that they are trying to
show that this witness is not credible
because they have lied and usually your
character for truthfulness is usually at
issue which is separate from your
general character and certainly separate
from whether you had a character to
engage in some sort of negligence on the
day in question so whether they take you
down the logical root of all the things
that come as a result of your lie or
whether they show you something that
contradicts your prior testimony so
whether it's a deposition or perhaps an
email that you wrote that contradicts
what you're saying on the stand a good
lawyer will be able to tell when you're
lying and they will Ram it down your
throat and show everyone that you are no
longer credible as a witness which i
think is about to happen right here
that's a silly question
because evolution doesn't exist of
course because evolution is it's not
real
yeah or they'll just catch you in some
other absurdity and ruin your
credibility that way that's that can
happen too okay I know at this point a
lot of people are going to say this is
completely unrealistic this is
ridiculous they're having a fake trial
in a bar so let's talk about what's
generally happening here and let's talk
specifically about legal arbitrations
let's think like a lawyer now an
arbitration is like a court and a trial
that happens in a court except it's all
done by private contracts so two parties
get into a dispute and rather than take
their dispute to court they either
decide at that time to do an arbitration
or they have a prior contract that
requires them to go to arbitration
arbitration can have some advantages it
can be much much faster than a court
which a court trial can often take years
to happen but it does have the
disadvantage of requiring the parties
themselves to pay the arbitrator or
arbitrators plural if there's more than
one so it can often be more expensive
than a courtroom proceeding if you want
to know more about arbitrations I
actually did a whole video about the
arbitration provision in the discord and
better health Terms of Service I'll put
a link to that down below believe it or
not when you go to arbitration all of
the rules are set by you and your
opponent you have to agree arbitration
is a creature of contract and a contract
requires mutual agreement so if you
agree to arbitration you and the other
party have to agree to the terms by
which that arbitration will proceed
so here the parties Dennis and Frank can
basically agreed to arbitrate their case
and avoid going to court even though
this is sort of the classic thing that
gets litigated in court negligence and a
car accident and they have sort of
agreed to be bound by the outcome of
what their three friends think about
this particular case so believe it or
not this is not that dissimilar from an
actual arbitration and it's a little bit
crazier but you could agree to sort of
forgo the rules of evidence if you
wanted to so that all of the testimony
that's coming in would come in in
arbitration too and you could agree to
be bound by what your three
friends think about particular case
these were all the smartest scientists
on the planet only problem is they kept
being wrong sometimes you fool this is
getting dangerously close to the
Chewbacca defense why would it look a
foot tall look want to live on Endor
with a bunch of two foot tall Ewoks that
does not make thin but more important
you have to ask yourself what does this
have to do with this case nothing which
ironically since that came out in South
Park is a term that lawyers use when we
talk about arguments that are completely
ridiculous and it have no bearing on the
particular case except for some specious
reasoning we actually do refer to things
as the Chewbacca defense have you seen
these fossil records have ice huh
have you pored through the data yourself
the numbers oh this thing is getting out
of hand so let me get this straight mr.
Reynolds you get your information from a
book written by men you've never met and
you take their words as truth based on a
willingness to believe a desire to
accept a leap of dare I say it faith I
think the writers of the show had a lot
of fun coming up with as many logical
fallacies as they possibly could cram
into 22 minutes none of this testimony
is relevant we've gone far afield I hope
we get back to the actual trial at hand
because there are some really
interesting legal issues to discuss here
reasonability foreseeability negligence
this is fun stuff or at least it was
come on look I mean I don't even know
how I'm supposed to respond to that like
and that is that's a false equivalency
yeah false equivalency to Reynolds sure
yeah okay I rest my case
[Music]
so Charlie here is getting the standard
wrong even though none of this is
relevant to the case at hand he's
talking about the criminal law standard
which is beyond a reasonable doubt you
cannot have any reasonable doubts in
order to find someone guilty in Criminal
Court it is the highest burden in all of
law whereas when you're talking about a
civil lawsuit you're only talking about
a preponderance of the evidence
something that is more likely than not
in other words if 50 percent is exactly
the same on either side all you have to
be is 51% sure then the plaintiff has
met their burden just 51 percent more
likely than not that the defendant
committed the acts accused of and that
that forms the basis of the liability at
issue yes exactly we shouldn't be
talking about this at all Oh Jay trial
to that hero cop Mark Fuhrman Songdo not
touching that one okay let's just get
back on track here I would like to make
my closing argument no no no no no no
this is going on long enough
and by the way deed why the hell do you
give about any of this anyway you don't
know you can't think of why I might like
to set a precedent of responsibility for
when someone's car gets destroyed No so
ironically arbitrations don't really set
legal precedent when you take a case to
court and that's adjudicated by either
the jury or the judge it really doesn't
have any presidential effect until one
of the parties takes that case up on
appeal so D won't get any precedent out
of this arbitration because it's not
taking place in court and is not taking
place in front of the Court of Appeals
if you can drive to your apartment and
back without spilling a single drop do
your pressing in a Centon Frank you pay
for everything fine good okay and Frank
if you can drive to our place and back
without getting an accident with me
giving you directions you can continue
to drive as long as I'm in the car with
you
deal all right animart is that go this
is amazing this is a great way to
resolve this particular dispute the
parties are agreeing to the facts
they're basically creating an objective
test to determine whether Frank was
negligent in the first instance based on
his lack of correct lenses in his
glasses and they're all agreeing to
these terms so they're setting a metric
by which everyone can agree this is
amazing I can't believe this is coming
as a result of this stupid show you know
there's no resolution and this is why
the law is hard sometimes they're just
gray areas that won't be resolved
it was Dee's fault so we have a trial me
and Charlie
there's too many trots
[Applause]
is that a just outcome I'll have to
think about that but it's a good lesson
that sometimes the law is just what
everyone agrees that the law is it's
just a construct based on society and
sometimes you get screwed because
everyone else is in the majority it's
already all right now it's time to give
this episode a grade for legal realism
this was a real treat it started with
one of the classic hypotheticals in law
school that you have to debate and there
are reasonable people on either side as
to whether you're responsible for
consequential damages then it goes
straight into something that is a
reasonable facsimile of arbitration
between private parties and despite all
the hijinks about nonsensical issues
with character and credibility and
evolution they actually have a lot of
good arguments ending with an objective
test to determine who is reasonably at
fault this was an enormous treat for me
as a practicing lawyer and someone who
really enjoyed all those philosophical
debates in law school I am so happy that
this episode of It's Always Sunny was
way better than the last one
so I'm gonna give this episode if it's
always sunny a solid be nice job you're
really improving in this class do you
agree
leave your objections down below and
check out my other reactions where I
will see you in court